Así es pues ese discurso ante estos
residentes franceses Era uno de los
puntos de su muy apretada agenda del día
de hoy allí en el discurso no muy largo
unos 15 minutos Pero así como ustedes lo
acaban de escuchar habló precisamente de
esa estrategia militar la nueva
estrategia militar que anunció el pasado
lunes el presidente antes de esta gira
africana y también volvió a reiterar que
Francia en ningún momento pues va a
interferir en los procesos políticos de
ningún país que se haga Bono o cualquier
otro país No solamente de África sino
del mundo esto haciendo pues una Clara
alusión a todas las series de de
protestas por parte de de la oposición
japonesa que ve con muy malos ojos la
visita del presidente mccom el hecho de
que esté pasando durante estos dos días
Pues reuniones con la presidente de ese
país salía un guimba una presidente que
ha sido muy cuestionado desde su
elección en 2016 y en todo caso pues
esto viene a sumarse al sin número de
protestas que ya se están dando en los
otros países que visitará el presidente
a finales de esta semana especialmente
en la República democrática del